what exactly is the problem with casual
relationships and how are you supposed
to find the person you need to be with
without having them
well
i think
how about abortion
that's a problem
and so
it's a minefield obviously any
discussion of abortion but one thing i
can say about abortion
that i think would
generate no
objection is you wouldn't give one to
your sister for a present
right
so whatever it is it's not desirable
and how not desirable it is is
at minimum open to question
so
i don't think there's any such thing as
a casual sexual relationship
i don't believe that i've never seen any
evidence that that's the case
i think that there are
people rationalize that constantly
because they want to believe while they
want to believe that
short-term hedonistic gratification is
ethically acceptable
and i don't think it is
i think that
it trains you to treat yourself and
other people as
instrumental objects of short-term
pleasure obviously well
is that is that how you want to train
yourself how's that going to work in
your
you're going to have a long-term
relationship at some point how are you
going to train yourself for that okay so
having said that
and then you know how carefully how
carefully should we conduct ourselves in
sexual matters i would say well
as carefully as you conduct yourself in
any matter of importance and that might
be
that stretches all the way up to the top
whatever the top is
you know you're going to treat the other
person as if they're a divine locus of
consciousness
or a disposable pornographic entity
well you know those are those are this
borders
okay but then you say well you have to
practice
and there's truth in that and
how do you practice and the answer is
well that's one of the central
complications of life
right to to get the balance between
individual
action and the whole domain of
sexuality and reproduction right is
perhaps there's no more difficult
question especially once you've solved
the question of do you have enough to
eat tomorrow
that'd be the next one that pops up
but
i don't think there's cat i don't think
there is such a thing as casual sex
i think that's indistinguishable from
masturbation which i also don't regard
as a particularly heroic act
and so well
t-shirts masturbation not a particular
oh yeah right right right and and i
think people have that sense and i don't
think that that's culturally
instantiated because in some sense we've
done everything we can
to eradicate every last vestige of
sexual shame which i think in the final
analysis is impossible because there are
all sorts of reasons for the persistence
of sexual shame that have nothing to do
with
cultural context
and
still you know it's an
affirmative and underground activity and
the reason for that is because it's
sub-optimal for all sorts of reasons
well
how much
motivation does a young man need to
overcome his fear of rejection and
establish a relationship with a woman
and the answer to that is
we don't know
but sexual deprivation could easily
easily be part of it
because
you to do something difficult you need a
lot of motivation
you need frustration working for you you
need fear working for you you need
lust working for you you need loneliness
working for you to bind a man and woman
together especially if they're going to
produce children this is a very very
difficult thing to do successfully and
so
anything that
interferes with that is to be viewed
with extreme skepticism and that's
undoubtedly part of the reason that
shame around
hedonistic sexual activities
remains a constant despite our best
attempts to eradicate it i think i would
also say
just from my experience growing up
especially in university
it's not
like it's seen on the outside having
casual sexual relationships as this fun
thing
it's not fun
no and nobody thinks it's fun especially
women so if you're around other girls
and they're like oh yeah i hooked up
with this guy none of you guys are
actually enjoying that yeah right and i
think that's a lie that women tell each
other um why
i think because they think other people
don't care and because if you do it it
makes you feel bad enough that you're
like well i don't want to look at
that
whatever's going on there like maybe me
feeling bad is not healthy right i'm not
sure and it means there's something bad
with you yeah or there's something wrong
with you right and so it's like and it's
unpleasant enough that you're like well
i'll just you know keep going it's
already happened there's nothing i can
do about it so it might as well be okay
because what am i going to do about what
am i going to do about it if it's not
okay yeah so then
you know and i think this is pretty
common for women in university to hook
up with people right it's called hookup
culture there's tinder like it happens
but i like for anybody out there who's
who's thinking maybe i don't want to do
that
it's not fun
it doesn't make you feel good it's
really makes you really lonely right
it's not good it makes you lonely
i think because what you're looking for
what you're looking for is a connection
with somebody and you're getting this
physical connection and you're not
getting any emotional connection
and it's
right and then there's the contradiction
oh it's a terrible contradiction yeah
and it's well here's here's an
interesting
thing i used to tell my clients is
don't do anything with anyone sexually
that you wouldn't talk to them about
it seems like well i wouldn't talk to
anybody about that it's like that but
you'll want to get out yeah yeah so
that's worth thinking about you're not
intimate enough with them
to have a conscious discussion but
you're perfectly willing to blunder
stupidly into it
and then and then risk the aftermath a
lot of that's fueled by alcohol too yeah
a lot of it is like all of it you're not
going to do if we ever ever wanted to
have a serious conversation about sexual
impropriety on campuses for example the
first thing we'd focus on is alcohol but
we don't want to have a serious
conversation about that because you know
we don't want to have
well we don't want to have chaperoned
parties like they were in the 1950s you
know it's like well you know
having some older people around
to keep the or the drunken orgy under
control actually turns out not to be
such a bad idea especially people who um
are non-biased right are unbiased who
are just there saying well this doesn't
look like it's going well maybe i'll
help this person yeah well instead of a
group of friends they're like no do it
like yeah right well which is a bunch of
doorknobs running into each other well
that's what you get with alcohol too
yeah and alcohol is really
alcohol is a drug that really
radically
decreases people's medium to long-term
orientation right it really focuses you
on the present which makes it if it's a
good drug for you it makes it
unbelievably fun because it decreases
anxiety
and it increases
likely opiate bonding and
dopamine mediated extroversion and so
like it's cocaine heroin and
benzodiazepine rolled into one
and so
it makes you not care and for for pure
hedonism there's nothing better than not
caring
but alcohol is a catastrophe on many
fronts because of that and a huge
proportion of violent crimes
exploitative crimes rapes a huge
proportion of those are
conducted between drunk people
so
but
i don't i don't believe that
i don't believe that there is moral
casual sex
because i don't think sex is casual i
don't think anything about it is casual
i don't think
well that that's what i